estas pastillas son solo una de las
nuevas herramientas en la lucha contra
el cobre 19 este jueves la fd aprobó un
nuevo antiviral fabricado por merck sólo
24 horas después de haber dado luz verde
a pax lobby de la píldora desarrollada
por facer ahora ya tienen planes de
aumentar la producción igual suelo en
sixty five housing works obtendremos 265
mil tratamientos the fighter disponibles
para enero con un aumento mensual de
píldoras a lo largo del año y un total
de 10 millones de tratamientos
entregados a finales del verano para
waits am mientras la pastilla de facer
reduciría las hospitalizaciones y
muertes en cerca de un 90% en grupos de
alto riesgo la de merck lo haría en un
30% ambas son antivirales que funcionan
evitando que el virus se multiplique las
píldoras podrían ayudar a aliviar parte
de la tensión en los servicios
sanitarios estadounidenses el país está
entrando en una cuarta ola de
coronavirus con un aumento de casos de
la variante omicron los nuevos fármacos
aprobados serán nuevas herramientas
útiles en la lucha contra el virus en un
principio habrá una dispone limitadas
sólo para los pacientes más vulnerables
emery puede haber ahora hemos pedido al
comité directivo del instituto nacional
de salud que elabore una recomendación
de cuando alguien llega con una
infección aguda y pertenece a un grupo
de riesgo ya que tenemos un suministro
limitado para tener una priorización de
cuál sería el mejor enfoque y best
aproach whitby
entretanto a las autoridades sanitarias
estadounidenses siguen llamando a que la
población se vacune salud en que una
persona tiene diez veces más
posibilidades de contraer kobe si no
está vacunada y veinte veces más de
morir por el virus en torno a 40
millones de adultos en el país todavía
no han recibido su primera dosis de la
vacuna